you know regardless of whether a lot of
people are traveling today or at least
they're trying to 12.6 million
passengers were expected at airports
across the country this weekend that's
the busiest labor day since before the
pandemic
omar villafranca is at dallas-fort worth
international airport this morning no
more good morning
good morning some folks are starting to
check in for their early morning flights
here at dfw it's expected to be the
fourth busiest airport in the whole
system more than half a million people
are expected to pass through here just
today now the other busy airports today
atlanta's hartsfield jackson denver
international and lax in los angeles
good news though we haven't seen many
cancellations so far this morning but if
you do experience a little travel misery
transportation department is launching a
new online dashboard to help passengers
compare airline compensation policies
for delayed or cancel flights now this
dashboard comes after a summer full of
coveted related staffing shortages and
severe weather that cause cancellations
and delays at airports across the
country now for those ending their
summer with a road trip drivers will
likely see some welcome relief at the
gas pump national average for a gallon
of gas 378 according to aaa that's down
82 cents from 460 the friday before
memorial day weekend and if you are
going to be hitting the road experts say
you should maybe leave early so you can
avoid traffic and avoid burning money
while idling in traffic and nikki i know
your dad experienced a little bit of
travel delays hopefully everything went
well for him
yes he was stuck right there where you
are in dallas last night omar thank you